j'avais mon dvd je l'écoutais tout âge
en écoute à 2 par nous dis-je los tres
india desjardins ou visionner la série
friends plus d'une fois pour elle ce fut
une véritable école il faut que je te
dise quelque chose de très important ça
c'est correct partie de comment je me
suis formé autant comme personne que
comme au triste parce que ça m'a appris
des façons de raconter des choses de
façon humoristique les conflits qui
reste dans le plaisir
c'était la première série à m sitecom à
mettre un arc dramatique de saison ceci
c'est vraiment intéressant parce que te
poses sont allés dans les symptômes
avant 25 ans après la diffusion du
premier épisode les six amis seront de
nouveau réunis à l'écran pour une
émission spéciale diffusée sur age
biomax aux états unis et sur crève au
canada des retrouvailles très attendues
par les millions de femmes partout sur
la planète
a new york les touristes se font encore
photographier devant la façade du
célèbre appartement de greenedge bénin
[Musique]
selon le magazine variety
les acteurs auraient été payés 2
millions 500 mille dollars chacun pour
participer à ces retrouvailles
et en plus de la distribution originale
les autres vedettes dont justin bieber
david beckham lady gaga est manal al
youssef va y participeront la spéciale
c'est que malgré le temps qui passe
l'émission continue de caracoler en tête
des séries les plus regardées sur les
plateformes de diffusion en continu
alors tout si tu vas des courses et pour
apprendre mais certaines blagues passe
moins bien aujourd'hui
des critiques ont déploré le manque de
diversité le caractère homophobe de
grosso fob où certains des vieux sketch
c'est tout mais critique près légitime
qu'on fait à la série qu'on peut
contextualisés par cette époque
[Musique]
malgré tout comme une millions de fans
india desjardins attend impatiemment ces
retrouvailles
parce que les amis c'est pour la vie
s'il est bien alexandre chartier radio
canada montréal
[Musique]
oui